Hello,
welcome to psychology to 30 personality
and its transformations.
It's called that because there are two
things that you have to take into
account when you're thinking about
personality and one of those is
how personality stays the same across
time and that's really what gives you
your identity and what allows you to
identify other people and then also help
personality changes.
We're going to
discuss both those things from a very
large number of perspectives
to find out all the information that you
need for the course.
All you have to do is type my name into
a browser and you'll get my home page,
which is the page that you see here on
the left.
There's a table of contents that says
current course,
and then up here there's also a table of
contents that lists the courses and this
one's this one,
and then this is the introductory page
here,
and then you can get to the course page
like this.
I don't really like blackboard,
so I'm going to use this instead.
So this is easy to get to and everything
you need to know about the core should
be here.
So we'll start with the very
straightforward things.
The first is there's,
there's two sources for reading in this
course and one is a paperback book,
which is called introduction to
personality and its transformations.
They're both chapters that I selected
from Classic Personality Textbook that
does a very good job of covering
classic personality theorists,
although not such a good job of covering
more recent work.
The book was published in 1982.
Freud hasn't changed much since 1982,
but there has been an awful lot of
personality research and so that brings
us to the second source of readings.
And the second source of readings is
actually this webpage.
So if you go down the webpage to lecture
topics and readings,
you'll see in the third column a whole
sequence of papers.
Now you have to pay attention to this
lectures and reading table more than
anything else because it tells you
what's going on for the for the duration
of the course and tell you what the
lectures are.
So today,
for example,
it's January seventh,
and so we're doing an introduction and
overview.
Maybe I could make that a little bigger
and next week,
no on,
on a Thursday we start with this reading
is called free forms of meaning in the
management of complexity and all you
have to use to get that reading is click
on it and then you get that reading,
which is a fairly straightforward
process.
Um,
you would probably like the lectures
better if you do the readings
beforehand.
Um,
that's,
it isn't necessary.
You can do this anyway you want,
but you'll get more out of the course I
think if you do that.
Um,
there's two Ta's for this course.
There are also listed here.
One is Vanessa Gauche and the other is
victor swift.
Their availability is listed here.
So Vanessa is available from 4:45 to
5:45 on Thursdays and victor is,
is available from 3:15 to 4:50 tuesdays.
Their office offices are listed there as
are their email addresses so that you
can get in touch with them.
My office hours are Wednesday from 4:15
to 5:45.
Now,
the way I handled that is outside my
office,
which is office four zero four six,
which is also listed there.
There are a number of signup sheets that
I'm just going to post on the wall.
Do that right after class because
they're printed out,
there's a number of signup sheets that
are listed on the wall and your best bet
is just to take a 15 minute slot.
Um,
don't take a whole bunch of them because
the student to teacher ratio in this
class is obviously quite high.
And so just take one for now if you
would,
and maybe if you have a meeting with me
you can check back later to see if
there's time for another one.
Um,
I would like to have more time than that
available,
but 90 minutes is what I can spare this
semester.
So anyways,
there'll be up today.
Now,
in terms of the mechanics of the course,
it's pretty straightforward.
There's no tricks.
Um,
there's two midterms.
The first one is February sixth and the
second one
is March 13th and there's also a final
and the midterm and the final is
essentially make up 75 percent of the
course.
It's actually 77 point five percent of
the course,
but
then there's two writing assignments.
The first writing assignment is an essay
and the essay has a number of different
due dates,
so if you're on the website you can go
to writing assignments and then you'll
see all these different topics that you
can choose from.
Now if you click on one of these,
you get to this little sign up sheet
here and then you can put in your name
and your email address and that signs
you up for that topic and as you can
see,
10 people can sign up for each topic.
So if you're in with a particular topic,
then you should sign up sooner rather
than later.
The due dates fall a little after the
course content that's related to that
topic,
so it will be the next class after the
lectures on that topic and dark,
spread them out across the year so that
the Ta's don't die,
a frustration and so that you guys can
get your essays back with a reasonable
degree of promptness.
Hopefully within a week.
Although let's say two weeks,
which seems reasonable.
So
the second
writing exercise,
which is worth seven point five percent,
BSA is worth 15 percent,
is a personality self analysis.
It's part of a suite of programs that I
designed called the cell fourth ring.
Sweet and I can show you those
and it's a cell phone ring.com
and I'll show you this video at some
point,
but for now
there's information here on these
programs,
but I'll give you a username and
password so then you can complete these.
And what you'll be asked to do is to
complete an exercise that's based on a
big five model of adjective description
of personality.
So since about 1930,
statisticians have been studying the
structure of language at a sentence
level and add an adjective level to
determine what the underlying
correlational structure of descriptive
phrases as they apply to human beings.
So for example,
if you're happy,
you're talkative and that might be
surprising,
but the fact that those two things are
tightly connected was one of the things
that was discovered by the factor
analytic processes that lead to the
development of the big five and the big
five.
They're roughly five traits as the name
might indicate extroversion,
which is a positive emotion trade
neuroticism,
which is a negative emotion trait.
Agreeableness,
which is warmth and empathy,
compassion.
Maybe the other side of that is kind of
a harsh coldness,
I guess.
Um,
openness which is both intelligence and
creativity and conscientiousness,
which is industriousness and
orderliness.
Now there are virtues,
so to speak and faults associated with
all of those dimensions.
So you can be too extroverted,
which makes you rather impulsive.
And if you're very extroverted,
it's more difficult to good grades and
university because you're always out
having fun with your friends and
partying.
And that might be good in that it will
help you develop a fairly extensive
social network,
which is a useful thing if you're
associated with people who are useful
for social networking purposes,
um,
but it can really interfere with your
ability to sit by yourself and study if
you're conscientious,
that's a good predictor of academic
success because conscientious people do
what they say they're going to do and
they seem to suffer shame and self
disgust and self contempt and guilt and
so on.
If they don't,
um,
if you get too conscientious though,
you can get quite
boxed in and,
and orderly and narrow in orderliness by
the way seems to be associated with a
railing,
political views.
And when it's extreme,
it's,
it starts to get repressive.
And so the point of all this is that
there are five traits and they have
positive and negative aspects,
especially at the extremes.
And these programs are set up,
first of all,
so that you'll see a series of
adjectives that are universal
descriptor.
So it's basically a small set of
adjectives,
100 that kind of cover each dimension of
personality with a reasonable degree of
comprehensiveness.
Then you'll be asked to pick which ones
you think are particularly relevant to
you and then you'll be asked to narrow
that to a final list in one half of the
exercise I'll list that represents your
virtues and then in the other half of
the exercise a list that represents your
fault.
Then you'll be asked to describe a time
when not virtue played a positive role
for you or when that fault interfered
with you and then you'll be asked to
describe how you might capitalize on
that virtue in the future or perhaps
Britain that fall under control in the
future.
And it turns out that writing exercises
of this sort,
I'm are very practically useful.
They have a variety of positive effects.
One of which seems to be an increase in
academic performance.
And our research so far has indicated
that that increase can be quite
substantial.
Among with similar programs.
At Mcgill we raised the academic
performance of struggling university
students by 25 percent.
So whole grade point and at a business
school in Holland where this is being
studied in some depth,
we've studied 2000 people,
they actually did the future authoring
program but not the present authoring
program,
which is the one you're going to do and
we improve their overall academic
achievement by about 30 percent as well.
Turns out that articulating yourself is
an extraordinarily useful thing to do
and you could actually.
You could also think about that in a
more comprehensive way
as the goal of safe psychotherapy and
personality transformation.
A lot of what's happening as you mature
and develop as a personality is that
what you are,
whatever that means.
I guess it's your behaviors and your
potential and I don't know exactly what
the potential is,
but your behaviors and your potential
can be increasingly organized at a high
level of consciousness articulated at a
high level of conscious.
There's an articulation is a funny word,
a because partly it means joint
articulation.
No,
your hands are very articulated and
that's why you can do a lot of things
with them and hands and speech are very
tightly related,
which is why most people,
speech centers are in the same
hemisphere as their dominant hand.
Anyways.
Articulating yourself makes you able to
do many more things with yourself and it
also seems to quell your negative
emotion,
partly because it's clarifying you.
You know the more you leave things muddy
in your life,
the less defined things are around you.
The more active your stress response
systems are because if things are murky
and undefined,
your stress systems basically assumed
that there are alligators and snakes and
predators hiding all that fog and gloom
and that you're in a very dangerous
environment.
But if you clarify that with careful
attention and articulation,
you can clear away the fog and the gloom
and that only leaves you with your
actual problems which once defined
carefully you might find manageable and
an example that would be.
You know when you go into your room and
you haven't done your homework for
awhile and there's piles of papers
piling up or maybe there's piles of junk
on your computer,
it doesn't really matter and you'll have
a very powerful tendency to avoid that,
not even to look at it,
right?
You don't even want to look at it
because it's and that's chaos.
It's sort of growing in your environment
and there's a specific part of your
brain which evolved to detect snakes
that deals with such little chaotic
piles of undone business and the more of
those that are around you
psychologically or physically,
the more negative emotions you
experienced,
the last hope you experienced and the
larger your stress response chronically,
and that's not good because if your
stress response is chronically elevated,
that suppresses your immune logical
function.
It makes you overweight,
predisposes you to diabetes and cancer.
It makes you age faster.
It increases the probability that you'll
have anxiety disorders and depression.
It's a bad thing,
so,
so clarifying who you are and what
you're doing is a good thing.
Unless you want all those other things
to happen,
which seems highly improbable,
although people desire some very strange
things and that's part of what we'll
talk about as this course progresses.
Okay,
so if you want to find out about the
course,
you can go to Jordan b Peterson Dotcom,
and the courses are listed there.
You just type my name into a search
engine and you'll find the courses.
This course is psych two to 30.
Obviously I mentioned if there's a
reading book,
would you have to buy the rest of the
readings are online,
the order that you do that reading is
listed on the syllabus.
You also have to do two assignments and
the essay,
which is only 750 words by the way,
but don't let that fool you because the
750 word essay can be very difficult to
write
the essay and then this personality
analysis.
Now the personality analysis,
all you have to do is show it to the Ta
to show them that you completed it
because we don't want to know what you
wrote down and we want to encourage you
to write down things that you know that
you'd like to write down that are likely
private,
unless you want to broadcast to your
faults on facebook,
which I suppose you knew after you
complete the exercise.
So the reason I want you to do that,
well,
there's three weeks.
That's right.
One is well,
it will familiarize you more with
standard models of personality because
you have to apply them to yourself and
so then you'll understand yourself
better too.
So that's a good thing.
And then it's also a clinical
intervention and some of you,
because you're in this course,
are no doubt interested in clinical
psychology and so this will give you a
flavor of the sorts of things that a
clinical psychologist might do except a
computer is doing it and then which,
which turns out to be fine.
People will actually often tell
computers things that they wouldn't tell
people because the computer doesn't care
what you've done particularly,
not yet anyways.
And uh,
the third reason is that while it should
be good for you and you know,
education should be good for you.
That's actually the purpose of
education,
right?
It's supposed to make you more healthy
mentally and physically.
It's supposed to make you more
productive.
And so that's what education is for and
that's what this class is for.
So that's what we're aiming at.
So then there's two exams,
two midterms,
25 percent each.
Approximately there are multiple choice.
Um,
I'll post sample questions so that
you'll know what they're like.
They're not tricky.
People get worried about exams and
rightly so,
but these aren't tricky dance.
If you do the readings and you come to
the class,
the probabilities quite high that you'll
do at least reasonably well.
Um,
I don't ask you to memorize dates and
that sort of thing.
I try to keep it at a conceptual level.
And so the questions on the multiple
choice tests are usually conceptual
questions where I try to get you to take
something that you've learned to read
and to apply it to the solving of a
problem,
even though they're in standard multiple
choice format,
there's,
there's usually not a tremendous number
of questions.
So you'll be able to complete the exams
in the time allowed without any trouble.
So
now let's see.
I should tell you guys who should take
this course and who shouldn't take it
because you need to know that since it's
your first day.
And so this course has two or three
aspects.
One aspect is scientific that really
occupies the last half of the course,
I would say it in the pre scientific
part of the course
with a purely research oriented element
of the course.
The first part of scientific too,
because science has more science,
more than mere testing of hypotheses.
Anyways,
the second half of the course deals
essentially with trait theory with
psychobiology.
So what I want to do is to tell you
about the basic dimensions of human
variability and also how those are
represented in the brain.
So that you can make a connection and
the body so that you can make a
connection between the theories and the
biological cognitive subscripts and not
sort of a unifying attempt.
So you bought to be interested,
not if you want to take this course and
you know,
and how did it go well for you.
So there's some psychometrics that's the
science of measurement because a little
bit of statistics,
here's a reasonable amount of
neuropsychology and some of it's
complex,
some of it isn't,
but I try to only pick things that I try
to only pick things to discuss with you
that are relevant at three levels of
analysis.
I want them to be personally relevant so
that they tell you something about
yourself.
I want them to be intellectually
relevant,
but I also want them to be culturally
relevant so that not all.
When you walk away from the study,
not only have,
you know something more about you and
your friends,
but hopefully you're a better
functioning creature in the broader
social meal.
You.
So,
so everything is picked to that end,
including the psychobiological or
neuropsychological material and the
trait material.
There's a fairly heavy,
heavy emphasis on
clinical issues.
The first half of the course deals with
classic theorists have personality and
all the classic personality theorists
were clinicians.
Now the UFT at present,
it doesn't have a clinical program,
although they're starting to get up in
scarborough,
but down here at St George,
there's not many clinicians.
I think I'm probably the only one.
I don't know why they let me in,
but we did and the thing,
the emphasis on that,
the emphasis of clinicians,
it's twofold,
right?
One is,
well who is the person or what is the
person,
but more importantly,
who could the person be or what should
they be?
And that's a very strange thing about
people,
right?
I mean if you have a cat,
you don't really sit around thinking
what could this cap b?
Because it's a captain,
you know,
if it has offspring,
there going to be cats and in the past
years there's still going to be just
cats.
But people.
Well,
we're strange in ways that are virtually
incomprehensible and we're not only what
we are,
but we're also what we could be and in
many cases,
especially for people of your age,
you're way more what you could be than
what you are and so focusing on what you
could be,
is it an extremely important thing to do
and in fact there's.
There's plenty of research and some of
it's associated with the writing
exercises that I told you about earlier,
that if you make efforts to define who
you could be and you know in a way that
you find interesting because he might as
well shape yourself into something that
you want to be,
that that increases the efficiency with
which you work substantially.
It also makes you a better person by
reasonable measures of better sort of
needs,
happier and healthier and more
acceptable or at least less repulsive to
other people.
So the clinical materials very useful
for that and the clinical material is
grounded in observation.
So it's kind of like ethos elegy.
He thought Ology is the study of animal
behavior,
but no one in the lab.
It's observational study,
a lot of the clinical stuff has this
observational quality to it.
It's heavily influenced by philosophy.
If you're not interested in ideas,
this is a bad course for you because
it's,
it's a course that private equity
concentrates on ideas.
I want them to have practical utility
because why not?
You want us?
We'll put constraints on them,
but,
but the fundamental focus is ideas.
And so when we discuss the clinical
material,
clinical personality material,
we'll discuss the philosophical
background of that and we'll do the same
thing when we get to the
psychobiological material.
So you want to decide if you're not
interested in philosophical ideas that
this is a bad course because you're
going to be stuck with,
with those sorts of things half the
time.
So.
And there's some,
there's some elements of the course.
They're almost straight philosophy
because some of the clinical schools,
especially those that were developed in
19 fifties,
like existential psychology are very
tightly associated with fields of
philosophy,
existentialism and phenomenology in that
case.
And so,
um,
I think that sort of thing is very much
worth learning because it's part of the
history of ideas and you should also
think about it and it's also very
interesting.
It's very useful to know something about
if you're going to be a clinical
psychologist,
because you should know a fair bit about
a lot of things if you're going to be a
clinical psychologist.
But even if you're interested in
research sciences,
have high hypothesis testing.
But the other half is I bought this
generation that's the most important.
After.
You've got to think up an idea before
you can test it.
And you know,
most of what you'll learn in methods
class has nothing to do with gender
research hypotheses.
They just tell you to do that first,
generate your research hypotheses.
It's like,
yeah,
that's the big problem right there.
The resident is just machinery,
right?
We'll just grind it through this
process.
And the way you generate research
hypothesis is by knowing something.
And so you have to learn a lot in order
to generate a research hypothesis that,
well first,
if someone hasn't already else hasn't
already thought of and disproved,
which is highly probable.
It's actually depressing.
Yeah.
But more and more knowledge because what
you find is that everyone's already
thought of everything.
And what was your ideas are stupid.
So
yeah.
anyways,
now let's see.
Oh yes.
Here's another reason not to take the
course.
There's a lot of reading and there's
less reading either was last year I took
out one paper that was too hard.
I think it was too hard for people even
though it was a great paper and left the
rest of the data.
And so
yeah,
if you're looking for a course with a
light reading load,
this isn't that course because this has
a heavy reading load now on the upside
for your essays,
I don't require you to read outside of
the course.
You can use the material that's in the
course to write the essay.
So it's self contained.
What?
There's a lot of reading and it's not
easy reading and partly because a lot of
it is original papers.
All the stuff that's listed on the web
is original papers and then the textbook
too.
It's tough textbook.
It's mostly text,
doesn't have a lot of pictures.
It has no stories at all about
celebrities.
I think that's the only text left.
Doesn't have stories about celebrities,
so
if you're.
If you're taking a tough course semester
and you don't have a lot of time to
read,
then well this isn't a course like that.
It's a course where there's an awful lot
to read and the thing about the reading
too is that you have to think about it.
You know like how fast you can read
something seems to be a function of how
complicated the words are.
That would be function one,
but the second function seems to be
something like how many ideas and there
are per paragraph or maybe per paid.
There are lots of ideas per paragraph in
these readings.
That's why I picked them.
So you can't just zip through them.
You have to think about,
well that's a good thing.
If you do read them,
you'll know a lot more at the end of the
class than you did at the beginning of
the class and you'll find that that
knowledge is extremely useful.
I truly believe that this knowledge can
change your life.
Well.
That's what it was generated for it,
right?
It's generated by clinicians and
personality psychologists.
That's what they're out there to do and
they're all fair to take revealed
potential.
It could be anything and to hammer it
and shape it into something that's hard
and pure and solid and you have to do a
lot of reading and writing that faking
to get to a point like that,
but it really beats the hell out of
mucking about in the murk and
unfortunately that's how many people
live and I've seen the consequences of
that.
And if you spend the next 30 years like
that,
you will be old by the time you're 50.
And so I would recommend that.
So it's worth doing the work.
It's really worth.
So let's take a look now.
Well first I'll ask you if there are any
questions.
Any questions?
Yes.
Oh yeah.
I'll get the user name and passwords up
to you pretty quick,
so I just have to make contact with the
guy designed it was to get the code,
so won't be long.
Can you find?
I hope so.
That's the plan.
Some of you have purchased it perhaps.
Okay,
so it appears that you can.
There's also maybe some old texts from
right slack floating about.
You can use those to do.
You can get a good deal on them.
You can often get them second hand on
Amazon for like 20 bucks.
If you look,
the old text is fine except that it has
more chapters in it,
but if you pay attention,
careful attention to the syllabus,
that won't be a problem because all the
chapters are numbered and all you have
to do is match the number on the
syllabus to the number in the book.
So other questions?
Okay,
so let's take a look at what we're going
to learn about
lecture too.
Okay.
So you can think of human knowledge.
In some ways it was branching into two
components.
You can take them to those two
components as knowledge about the
subject of world and knowledge about the
objective world.
That's one way of thinking about it.
The other way you could think about it
is knowledge about what things are and
knowledge about what to do.
Now.
Most of what you learn in university is
knowledge about what things are,
but that's only half of what you need to
know because you really need to know
what you should go about and do.
This is a real problem for human beings
because we're always trying to having to
think up what we should be doing next
and like that's the fundamental question
of life,
which is,
well,
what should I do next?
Or what should I do tomorrow?
Or what should I do next week or next
month or next year?
Because that's another problem about
being human is that not only do we have
to figure out what to do next,
but we can also see the future or
multiple futures even,
and then we have to determine what those
futures could be and how to avoid others
that we don't want to have come into
existence at all and then how to
configure our behaviors so that as we
navigate through the potential futures,
we land up more or less somewhere we
want and not somewhere we really don't
want,
and so that's a real problem and one
that's an existential problem in fact,
and what that means is that we need
knowledge about the subjective and about
the behavioral.
It's part of potential.
How do you unravel yourself across time.
Now it's proved very difficult for human
beings to formalize that kind of
knowledge.
Now we formalized scientific knowledge
which has more knowledge about what
things are and about the objective
world,
the scientific method,
especially the research method,
formalizes or knowledge about the
objective world and about what it's made
of,
but it doesn't give us much insight into
what to do about that.
All.
It seems to do actually is increase our
power to do things but not necessarily
to inform us as to the direction in
which that power should be exerted and
you don't really have to look any
farther than the 20th century if you
want historical proof of that,
because as people got more and more
powerful so that we could sit in this
lovely classroom and all be warm and
cozy,
while it's terrible outside,
we also learned how to kill each other
with unprecedented
Gusto and potency.
And so science has enabled us on both
sides and that's how it is.
Good or bad.
On the behavioral side,
there's a tradition of knowledge and
it's an ancient tradition and it's
grounded in forms of knowledge that are
likely tens of thousands of years old or
maybe even older than that.
And those are forms of knowledge that
are essentially mythological for
religious.
And the reason that I start with those
is,
first of all,
religious systems are in many ways
theories of personality.
Um,
and there's very tight associations
between certain religions and certain
fields of psychology.
So Judaism that's been identified fairly
heavily with Freud and Christianity with
Carl Jung's work and also with Carl
Rogers,
Rogers was actually a seminarian and a
lot of the ideas about what a person
could be.
So these are ideas about the ideal are
derived from religious and mythological
substrates because they have to be
derived from somewhere.
Right?
And so you think,
well,
how do people get their ideas about
what's possible or what should be.
Part of it is through storytelling.
That's why you go to movies,
right?
You go there to see what people could be
and you enact all those people on the
screen with your bodies while it's
happening and you have a little neuro
system that does that.
So it puts you right in the action.
It's an amazing ability,
amazing human ability.
And the reason we're so attracted to
that sort of thing is because we want to
know what to do with ourselves and
there's a very large body of very
complex information that pertains to
that.
One of the things that Carl young set
was that one of the things he believed
was that that form of knowledge have
developed quite explicitly up to about
the time of the renaissance or a boat at
the time of the Bacon and descartes who
founded and Galileo,
who basically found the scientific
method and then we sort of stopped
developing that kind of knowledge and
the knowledge of the objective world
leapt ahead and in like exponentially
and so that's left us with the same
moral intelligence we have in the 17
hundreds,
but with 21st century technology,
not necessarily a good thing.
So part of what we're doing in a sense
is rescuing the past.
No.
In my other class sometimes I show
Pinocchio the movie.
How many of you Seen Pinocchio?
I launched,
so yeah,
it's like the most popular animated
movie ever made seconds I think is the
line more partner.
There's one saving for Nokia where
Pinocchio rescues is farther from a
whale.
You may remember that.
You may notice that you watched that and
that was perfectly fine as far as you
were concerned that you could watch on
puppet swim with a cricket to the bottom
of the ocean and rescue his father from
a whale.
It's like,
okay,
so the first thing you might think about
is how in the world could you sit there
and swallow that and not even notice.
Notice,
notice that you were doing something as
absurd,
as bizarre as any ritual you can
possibly imagine while it's partly
because we're very attracted to
narrative and narrative's have
structured narrative through both
behavior and they have a deep structure
and they have a deep symbolic structure.
So for example,
the whale in Pinocchio wasn't just any
ordinary whale because if you remember
it also breathe,
smoke and fire.
It's very strange behavior for a whale
and not make even a window that strange
and that made it a dragon and so part of
what that meant was the Pinocchio was
rescuing as far as from a dragon.
That's a very old story.
In fact,
that story is the oldest story that we
have in written form.
It's a variant of a story that was told
by the Mesopotamians pump 5,000 years
ago,
so
part of that story means when you should
rescue your father from what?
Well,
from the murky chaos in which your
culture is embedded.
No,
you guys are all inheritors of rich
cultural traditions.
You know those aren't just words.
Those cultural traditions orient you.
They keep you sane and if they're
desiccated,
the broken up and dad in archaic,
in line,
in the bottom of the chaos,
then you better get them back out of
there because without them you're going
to live shadow and difficult lives and
that's a bad idea.
So starting with the historical
perspectives,
we can situate ourselves in maybe some
hundreds of thousands of years of
history,
maybe even longer on I can.
I can tell you in one manner might be
longer.
It turns out that part of the reason
that we can see so well with which we
can,
human beings can really see well way
better than almost any other animal
except hunting birds.
Hunting birds can see better than not,
but other than not,
man,
it's us and that's especially rare among
mammals in particular,
the rare among primates.
So you might yourself,
well,
why can we see so well?
Well,
it turns out that part of the reason is
that we call evolved with predatory
snakes.
So predatory snakes are newer than
lizards by the way,
even though you wouldn't think so.
Aaron,
there's a woman at Ucla named Lynn
Isabelle,
who was thinking,
why do people see so well?
And so she went.
She had the snake detection theory
because she'd worked with primates.
She knew they could really see the sort
of camouflage patterns that snake hats,
name,
Tab,
and the motion that they make.
They're really good at detecting now.
Plus human beings are very afraid of
snakes innately.
Plus,
if you date chimpanzees who've never
seen a snake and you throw a rubber
snake in their cage,
assuming they're in a cage,
then they jumped to the top of the cage
and because they're not happy about that
snake,
but then they look at it and then if
they're out in the jungle juggling
around and they see a baby snake,
then they have a specific sort of pride
they make and they'll stand there for
like nine hours watching a big snake
making this noise and all the other
chimps depending on how afraid they are.
Also come and look at the snake.
And so yeah,
because they want to know what that
sneaks up to you and that's what we want
to know too.
We want to know what the snakes are up
to.
That's for sure.
And the circuit that we developed to
detect snakes.
The visual circuit is partly what gives
us such tremendous acuity of vision.
And partly the way Isabelle figured that
out was by correlating primate visual
acuity with the press and its
development over evolutionary time with
the prevalence of predatory snakes in
that geographical region.
And she found that there was a very high
correlation,
so we can see sharply,
partly because we're always looking for
snakes and you know that pile of I'm
done homework in your,
in your,
in your room,
that's snakes as far as the part of your
brain that developed to deal with snakes
is concerned.
And so you know,
if you leave a lot of things undone
around you,
then all you've got snakes and you're
their target and so that's no way to
live.
And so that whale down there at the
bottom of the ocean,
that's kind of a very of snake to
dragging,
even though it's a whale breathes fire,
right?
So let's call it the dragon.
That's what it is.
And the idea that you have to rescue
something from the drag is an
unbelievably old story.
And so that's partly what we're going to
be doing at the beginning of this
course.
We're going to be going way back to the
merch and mark of prehistory trying to
understand what the hell we've been up
to for the last 60 million years because
that's when our tree dwelling ancestors
first really started to deal with
predatory snakes and my suspicions are
that you're all evolved from one of
those little tree dwelling rats.
The first one who figured out that if
you drop the snake stick on a snake,
it would probably run away,
so that's what we've been doing for 60
million years.
Throwing sticks at snakes.
So that's the first lecture and
you'll see why when you do the reading,
why this is broadly relevant because it
also accounts at least in part for the
human tendency to demonize people who
aren't like us because it turns out that
we use the same circuit that we would
use to handle predatory reptiles.
Let's say we use that circuit,
the first process.
People who are strange to us and it
makes sense because people who were
strange to us,
who come from different cultures and who
represent different ideals are
unbelievably dangerous.
Even though they might also be
unbelievably beneficial.
You know,
the coordinator of Americans,
they came out and they shook hands with
the Europeans and then 95 percent of the
dive,
the next one,
hundred and 50 years,
right?
They all died in our place.
He died of smallpox.
They died of measles,
measles,
just wipe them out.
By the time the pilgrims came to North
America,
which is,
you know,
fairly early in North American European
history,
95 percent of the Indians were already
dead.
They were welcomed in the Europeans
because they didn't have any people get
their crops off.
So meeting someone who strange is no
trivial thing,
and even if they don't poison me with
some horrible illness,
they'll come along with some cockamamie
idea like Marxism and you'll be Chinese
and then it will be the 20th century in
the 100 million of you will die.
It's very useful to understand the deep
mythological structures that we live
inside and their relationship to our
brain and our body really gives you
insight into how people function.
It's helpful.
The next lecture is on heroic and
Shamanic initiations and that brings us
closer to the present than say 60
million years ago.
It's more like 50,000 years ago and
there are shamonic traditions all over
the world and the Shaman is kind of the
precursor to the to the to the to the
man of intelligence,
to the man of intellect,
the man of culture,
and he's sort of a doctor and a
scientist and a priest all wrapped up
into one thing and he's often the person
who's in charge of culture.
Many in many societies,
the Sherman has a vocabulary vocabulary
that vastly exceeds that of his peers
and that's because he's been taught it
in his initiatory process so that the
culture within which that particular
people survives can be
transmitted down the generations with
very little error.
People can remember things that are
transmitted verbally.
It preliterate cultures with
unbelievable accuracy.
Under the shamanic initiation is very
interest in the heroic initiations as
well are very interesting processes
because they involve.
They involve death and rebirth and death
and rebirth is more or less equivalent
to change.
So here's something to think about.
So only if there's a mosquito and wants
to make another mosquito,
it basically lays 10,000 eggs,
right?
And then all those eggs hatch and 9,999
of those little mosquitoes die and then
one mosquito makes it and lays another
10,000 days.
So it's pretty costly reproductive
strategy,
right?
So the way the mosquito works is that it
knows that the world is chaotic and
dangerous and it has no idea how to
survive in that.
So it just makes a whole pile of
mosquitoes and in hopes that one of them
will sneak through and each of those
mosquitoes is a tiny bit different from
each other.
Mosquito in terms of kind of place and
also genetic structure.
And maybe one's got some little
advantage that allows it to survive,
but it's costly,
right?
It's 99,999 to one.
Otherwise we'd be covered with
mosquitoes.
So.
So the way in the mosquito deals with
the fact that you can't figure out
what's going on is by producing lots of
mosquitoes.
But the way people figure out what's
going on is by producing lots of ideas.
And ideas are the relationship of ideas
to you and the external world is the
same as the relationship of animals to
the environment.
So there's a philosopher,
Alfred North Whitehead who said,
human beings evolved to let their ideas
die instead of them.
Now that's a smart way of thinking
because it means that you can put us off
a little sub personality of yourself.
Maybe it's angry subpersonality or said
seven personality or an irritated or
presented folder,
you know?
No,
there aren't exactly.
The idea is they're more like little
spirits that are partly you.
They're kind of stupid because they've
only go one direction,
but there's still variance of you and
maybe you can present one of those to
someone which you might do if you're
dating someone and you want to,
assuming you still do that.
If you're dating someone and you want
to,
we've pressed them.
Maybe you spin off some little variance
of yourself that you think is
particularly attractive,
probably won't work.
I noticed that work and if it doesn't
work well,
then you can get all heartbroken and let
it die.
And then maybe the next one you spin off
will be a little more,
you know,
together.
And so that's how people progress a
progress by dying and coming back to
life at different levels.
And I mean maybe you're just taking some
little ratty mistake and so you can let
it go and you're only shaved momentarily
and it's only a little pain when that
circuit dies or maybe it's your whole
damn personality that has to go,
you know,
that happens to people when they
encounter a catastrophe of one form or
another.
So that might happen to someone close to
you dies.
Or if you lose a landlord,
if you get an illness or you know,
any of the horrible things that planning
people to very deep levels,
which might mean pretty much all of you
has to go and maybe you'll actually
died.
But if you don't,
well you can let go of what's holding
you back.
And maybe that's your old self and then
you can come back to life.
And I will tell you it's a lot better to
do that voluntarily before.
It's that in voluntarily in a moment of
crisis.
And I would say in some ways that's the
lesson of clinical psychology.
Confront the damn snakes first because
it's really hard to get out of their
bellies once they beat on you.
So the shopping is shamonic.
Initiations are death and rebirth
initiations.
They formalize that you're often the
rituals themselves are often accompanied
by the use of different classes of
hallucinogens,
which for one reason or another seem to
facilitate at least symbolically the
process of transformation from life to
death and back to life.
So there are dramatizations of the
process by which people learn.
You learn something to really learn some
presupposition that you had before that
has to crumble and then the new
information comes in and you can build a
new self around it,
but that's a painful process and that's
part of why people stick to their ideas
or their past selves.
No one
you could stick to your past self and
that would be fine,
except that everything's changing around
you all the time.
And so if you don't change,
then you just get more and more
outdated.
You're more and more archaic.
None of your precept positions of work
anymore.
And so you're like,
you're like this rusty machine clanking
around,
running into things all the time when
your life is miserable because you don't
fit the environment anymore.
And so when I talk about personality and
its transformations,
something that you could ask yourself,
which is in some way the most
fundamental question you can ask
yourself is,
are you the thing that stays the same or
are you the thing that changes and you
know,
the thing that changes can live in a lot
more places.
And so that's we're thinking about,
but the cost is well,
when you changed your diet a little bit
and that's painful or maybe you die a
lot and that's really painful.
So if you ever wonder why people don't
change,
that's part of the reason.
Then we.
The next section is on constructivism.
We're going to talk mostly about PSA is
not actually a developmental
psychologist.
I like piaget because Piaget had an
interest in question is,
which is,
it's not the genetic question or an
environmental question.
You know,
you might think those are the only two
kinds of questions there are when you're
thinking about the tall,
but it's not exactly that.
Here's why
it's not clear to what degree your
specified by your genes.
So here's one possibility,
so let's say that encoded in your
genetic structure or whole variety of
potential use,
like who knows how many,
oh,
the potential use,
but the entire history of mankind been
able to weave into their genetic
structure.
They're all sitting down there encoded
in your genes and then that very complex
structure that's rife with potential
pops out into a particular environment
and then it interacts with that
environment like a program interacts
with the computer and gathers
information of one form or another that
takes that information and the material
that is appropriate and builds the real
you out of that.
And that's what piaget was studying.
He was trying to figure out how as a
child go about taking itself from this
thing that just lays there squawks
basically to something that's,
you know,
you go on Youtube and you see what
people can do,
what human beings can do.
It's bloody unbelievable.
I mean we're sold ridiculously
versatile.
People can do things that are just
impossible in,
in every dimension,
you know,
intellectually,
physically,
spiritually,
it,
even eat,
hotdogs,
set a rate that you can hardly imagine.
We're very variable and Pinochet was
very interested in trying to figure out
how all of that embodied variability
could come out of this little package of
potential at the beginning of life.
It's very interesting.
So that's constructivism.
How does the individual construct him or
herself from nothing in some ways from
birth forward and so Psj,
especially his discussion of infant
development,
sort of like the analysis of the
unfolding of a human being and because
people were doing full to you though,
because babies when they're born they'll
crunched up like this and so they have
to stretch out and you know,
get going and I was concerned so.
So that's,
that's good.
And then we go from there to depth
psychology.
You might think about that more a
psychoanalysis now
people
have,
people aren't very happy generally
speaking about psychoanalytic theory,
especially if they're research oriented,
but there's a variety of reasons for
that.
And one of the business,
they don't know anything about it.
That would be the first place.
And then people are often tempted to
denigrate anything they don't
understand.
It's actually kind hard to understand
psychoanalytic thinking.
It's in fact,
it's very hard.
And the other thing about like
scientists and research scientists who
are engaged in psychological work is
they're actually usually fairly mentally
healthy.
You know,
at least they're healthy enough to be
scientists,
which you know,
you've got to be pretty healthy to be a
scientist,
to go to be disciplined,
you got to be able to get up and go to
work every day.
You have to be able to think about
complex things.
You have to be very orderly and
persistent,
you know?
And so there's a lot of demand on you if
you're a scientific researcher.
So the problem with scientific research
is they hang around with other
scientific research,
then they think that's what human beings
are like.
And human beings are nothing like
scientific researchers.
There are a tiny minority of the
population.
There is bizarre.
It's like Albino Buffalo and to to think
of them as representative of human
beings is insane.
First of all,
most of them have high in the 99th
percentile,
so it's like why bother even thinking
about them?
Normal human beings are very weird,
especially the ones that don't function
well and not functioning well is
bottomless pit that that's why hell is
because not functioning well.
It's a bottomless pit and if you're
dealing with people who aren't
functioning well,
one of the most mysterious things is how
they can take a situation that's gone
off of beyond your worst imaginings and
then think up three or four creative
ways to make it worse.
Ten,
if you're dealing with somebody like
that and you do,
if you're a clinician,
if you're dealing with someone like
that,
good luck with your behavioral
interventions.
Man,
that's like throwing sticks at an
elephant.
You're just going to get anywhere and
one of the ways I want to demonstrate
this to you,
I'm going to show you a film called
crumb crumbs.
A harsh film,
but it's the best documentary by the
way,
of an underground comic named Robert
Crump who's actually quite a genius even
though he's perverse in precisely the
Friday in ways that are interesting and
his brothers or even worse,
so I'll walk you through that because I
can't figure out any other way of giving
you a taste of what Freudian
psychopathology is like.
It's not pretty and that's the other
reason that sort of clean minded
research scientists don't like
psychoanalytic thinking because it's
really in many ways it deals with the
most disgusting elements of human
behavior and so
it's not even that pleasant to think
about.
And then there's you who will talk about
after Freud and young is so strange that
he makes Freud look normal and you
believed that as,
as I mentioned earlier,
I believe that there is a universal
grammar of ethics,
of morality.
It's not arbitrary.
It's not relative.
You know,
in the universities,
the theater has been,
at least since the 19 sixties that one
person's ethics is as good as another
person and there's no way of
distinguishing reliably between them.
Well,
I happen to think that's absolute
nonsense.
It's also extremely dangerous nonsense
and I also think there's no evidence for
it whatsoever because we now know a lot
about human universals,
which are aspects of human behavior that
are constant across all cultures and
there are a lot of them.
There are a lot of at.
The other thing is there's just not that
many ways that half mad primates can
gather together in large groups and live
productively.
It's not easy like you think of all the
civilization work that went into
allowing all you people from all these
different cultures to sit here in peace
and comfort.
It's mind boggling if you think there's
a million ways to do that.
Well think again,
maybe there's one way to do that,
you know,
and we do it well enough.
So here we are and no one's being knifed
so,
so that's you.
And he's profound beyond belief really
beyond belief.
So that's.
Those guys all dealt with unconscious.
Now.
It's interesting to think about what the
unconscious means and so I can give you
a bit of a hint.
It's,
it's partly the information that's coded
in your behavior,
so for example,
there are a lot of things that you can
do with your body that you don't know
how you do,
like you don't know how you want,
for example,
or how do you ride a bike or how you
talk.
You can talk,
but you don't know how you talk.
You just move your mouth.
I hope you get the point right.
You have no conscious apprehension
whatsoever of the micro details that are
necessary to allow you to move your
mouth so there's a lot of information
encoded in you that you don't have
conscious access to and it's not only
physiologically and code.
It's also culturally encoded because
you've been targeted and shaped by the
interactions of all the people you've
ever encountered and they in turn by all
the people they've ever encountered,
including their ancestors.
So you're the product of this
unbelievably complex,
multigenerational exchange of
information that in some ways is all
about how to make you acceptable to the
public.
And there's only certain ways you can be
acceptable to the public.
You know,
you have to be relatively clean,
for example,
at least in our society,
you can't be too boring or you won't
have any friends.
You also can't be too excited.
No,
you can't be too violent.
You can't be too empty headed unless
you're associating with people who liked
to feel superior.
You know there's,
there's.
We put a lot of demands on each other in
terms of what constitutes acceptibility,
let alone ideal.
We're always telling each other about
both of those.
What's acceptable,
what's ideal.
Every interaction you have shapes you
into an approximation of acceptable in
ideal,
and that's all encoded in youtube.
It's encoded in your behavior.
It's also encoded in your imagination
and that's why you can go to a movie and
you can instantly identify the hero and
the villain,
which is of course the first thing you
do when you go to a movie because
otherwise it can't make sense out of it,
and so that encoding prior to
articulation,
that's on the unconscious and that's
what the psychoanalysts were interested
in analytics.
Now the cognitive neuroscientists have
kind of gone up there too,
but there's.
They're deluded into thinking that
what's in your head is information and
that it's ideas and those are sort of
cold and dead things and your hand is
not full of ideas and information that's
full of devils and snakes and the
psychoanalysts knew that,
and by that I mean you're alive and so
are your sub components and all your
little subpersonalities and aren't just
ideas.
They see,
hear it,
feel it,
have aids.
As you know.
For example,
when you get possessed by anger,
the anger can be entirely destructive.
I want to bring down the person I love
half an hour later you're like,
what the hell was I thinking about it?
Like,
yeah,
no kidding.
Well,
you weren't thinking.
You're just possessed by some
personality and that's what the
psychoanalysts were interested in.
Subpersonalities fantasies.
Next week,
go to the humanists and the
existentialists.
Now they're interesting because they
come at the problem of what's wrong with
people from a kind of universalist
perspective.
Now for fraud,
if you weren't sick,
you were healthy and that seems obvious
because we think you can make a clear
distinction between second healthy but
the existentialists.
They didn't want any of that.
Their hypothesis was if you're human,
you're sick,
there's no way out,
and the reason you're sick in a sense
and unlike any other animal is the life
itself poses a paradoxical problem to
you,
partly because you're so conscious
because you're self conscious and
actually a sequence of paradoxical
problems.
A how do you live when you're vulnerable
and mortal?
That's a rough one because you might
say,
well,
why should I go on at all or who's going
to know anyways in the thousand years
are a million years or why is there
suffering,
or how do you go on in the face of
cruelty?
Those are questions that grip at
people's soul and crush it and they're
not a consequence of mental illness.
It's like,
what?
How long should it take you to recover
if your whole family is wiped out in a
car accident?
What's healthy?
Well,
we don't know the answer to that.
It's like,
shouldn't you ever recover?
Maybe a fewer halfways in path that
would just kill you.
You know,
a lot of times people can't recover from
their grief because they're building.
If they,
how can I?
How can I live with all of those people
close to me died and they died on
therapy.
That's an existential problem.
And then there's one class which is
vulnerability and more talented.
Everyone's got that stereotype.
So how do you deal with that hard
question.
Second class of problems?
Well,
everybody's always evaluating always and
you're never good enough.
So what that means is that you're always
in an insufficient relationship with
society in history.
No matter how good you get,
it's not good enough.
And so history itself as well as culture
always faces you as a judge.
And so that's the second category of
existential problem.
Then the third problem is well,
what to do about you yourself know
there's nature you have to contend with
and there's culture you will have to
contend with,
and then you've got yourself and your
self consciousness and your deep
knowledge of all the things about you
that could really use some repair.
And the thing about those prompts is
that everyone has them and they always
have the,
as far as we know,
they always will,
and so they're built into the condition
of being human.
And that's what existentialism is about.
It's like life is a paradoxical problem.
Is there any possible solution to a
paradoxical problem?
Well that's,
that's,
that's in some ways the question of the
meaning of life.
And one hint is that what?
What's the meaning of life?
And one answer to that is this is the
hand,
is that the meaning to life is the
pattern of thought and action that you
take that enables you to tolerate at
least tolerate the conditions of luck.
And then maybe you could move one step
beyond that.
If you're feeling a little optimistic
and say meaning of life is the pattern
of consumption inaction that enables you
to welcome the conditions of life and
then you might ask yourself,
is there such a mode of being given the
nature of the problem that you have to
contend with it?
Is there actually a motive be that would
enable that?
You could say the vulnerability,
the judgment,
the insufficiency,
it's worth it under these conditions and
that's the other existential question.
The people who post those questions,
they weren't messing around.
You're going to read people like frankl,
Viktor Frankl and their social needs and
what those do people live through.
I mean it's unimaginably horrible and
when they were wrestling with the
questions that I just described,
they weren't academic.
They weren't academic issues.
They were embodied issues of life and
culture and genocide and cruelty
and so their examination of that had to
be deep enough
to be able to contend with questions
like that and answers that are deep
enough to contend with.
Questions like that are frightening
answers
and we have reading week,
it'll be a relief.
The last part of the course,
this is when we switched over to the
more scientific domain and so we're
going to do two things.
As I said,
we're going to take a pretty deep look
at how the brain functions as far as we
know in our current state of
unimaginable ignorance like we're.
We really know so little about the brain
or maybe we know a bit of a bit about
the brain,
but we certainly don't know anything yet
about consciousness and consciousness
seems to be a very relevant part of the
brain,
right?
It's sort of the part that everybody
cares about.
Six consciousness in some sense seems to
be you even more than your brain is you.
I mean,
your brain's just this thing inside your
skull,
but your consciousness,
you know,
that's your being.
We don't have a clue about
consciousness.
I our scientific,
we're not even able to conceptualize it
in a scientific manner.
It's a real mystery.
So,
but having said that,
there's still plenty of things that are
interesting to know about the brain.
One of the things we're going to do,
and this is sort of associated with the
idea of the end,
you know,
the end for Freud was the natural self
and so that was your primordial.
You could think about them as drives or
temptations or,
or values.
Values is probably the most accurate
anger,
sexuality,
those are the top two,
Friday and concerns.
There's plenty others eating for didn't
care about that we do now because
everyone has an eating disorder or
virtually everyone.
So for the Victorians it was sexuality.
For us it's food.
Sex doesn't seem to be a problem,
but we just can't eat anymore.
So we're going to take a look at the low
level biological systems in the brain
and those are systems go on.
Some of those systems are so old that
even crustaceans have.
So for example,
this is so cool.
So if you give a lobster who's being
defeated in a dominance fight because
they fight for dominance and they might
even know it if you mean the lobster.
If you take a lobster who's been
defeated in a dominance dispute,
he'll go back to his little lobster hole
and pout and when out and he gets all
collapsed and you can't even read it.
Get them out of his hole with a stick
because he's going to sit in there and
be upset about his dominance defeat and
maybe he'll come on with kind of a new
lobster already.
Go again and maybe not.
If you take that same lobster and you
give him anti depressants right after he
fights,
he won't go back into his cave and hide
and he'll fight right away again,
and so you think about that.
That means that the circuitry that
underlies our defeat related depression
is 300 million years old and even
crustaceans have
so that's way down in your brainstem
man,
because lobsters hardly even have
brains.
In fact,
if the last year has been tough and he's
been launched here for a long time and
he gets defeated badly,
then when he goes off to pout,
he has to dissolve as whole brain is.
All he does is dominant stop.
Then it grows a new subordinate brain
weasels around with that for now.
So and that's useful to think about the
next time you to get defeated because
all that pain you're going through,
it's like you've got some circuit
repairs to make and if you've been badly
defeated,
well maybe you should just let yourself
collapsed and all of that stuff clear
away so you could come back.
So that's low level stuff.
Brainstem stuff.
It's way down at the bottom of your
being,
you know,
but we're going to talk about systems
that are above that too,
but still low.
The hypothalamus,
for example,
it's a very cool brain area.
It sort of responsible for all the basic
drives,
hunger,
temperature,
regulation,
sexuality,
um,
defensive aggression,
predatory aggression.
It looks like it's something different.
Everyone has those systems,
you know,
so they're like these sub beings that
live inside us,
but they're also preconditions for
communication.
You know,
because you might say to your friend or
an angry today and your friend doesn't
say,
well,
what do you mean angry?
He says,
well,
what happened to upset?
Because he knows what anger begins and
the reason he knows that his,
because he's already it in his head.
He's like,
you.
He gets angry,
get sad,
gets afraid.
Basic emotions,
but not only the basic emotions,
but the basic motivations.
And so we're gonna.
Look at the brain systems that underlie
the basic motivations and the basic
emotions.
And in some sense those systems are
equivalent to the physiological
incarnation of the end.
That Freud described that the end of the
19th century.
And so that's a nice way to look at it.
You'll build through the psychoanalytic
thinking,
which,
which kind of puts flesh on these
systems because for the psychoanalyst,
and this is why they're still relevant.
Those weren't just systems.
Hey,
we're living personalities.
Narrow one I personalities,
they only want one thing,
but personalities nonetheless,
ancient gone.
That's another way of looking at and
things.
You have to condense it again with
whether you believe in them or not.
We'll discuss all five traits as well.
Extroversion,
as I said,
that's positive emotion.
Neuroticism,
that's negative emotion.
People vary on those dimensions.
Agreeableness,
that seems to be associated with
maternal behavior on one end and
predatory hunting on another because
human beings are hunters and mammals.
It's a weird combination,
right?
Because if you're a hunting panel,
you got to figure out how not to kill
and eat your children.
Right?
And that happens in lots of mammalian
species,
especially among the males.
So they have to be moved away,
but he would have solved that more or
less.
You know,
it gets complicated in mixed families
because if you're the child of the step
parent,
you have 100 times the likelihood of
being abused,
so we'll talk about conscientiousness,
which is a great predictor of longterm
life success,
but also associated with fascist
political priest predispositions because
it turns out that the way you vote has
very little to do with what you say and
very much to do with what your
temperament is.
So even for high level cognitive
functions like political belief,
these underlying systems play in
determining role.
Last two things.
We're going to talk about performance
prediction and by that I mean well,
there's been accruing evidence.
You might say,
what?
What,
How do you have a happy life?
First of all,
I wouldn't say that's a stupid question,
but we'll go because happiness isn't.
It's not the right eight.
It's,
it's a way.
It's not a place to go.
It's a matter of manifestation while
your journey,
something like that.
Leaving that aside,
what do you need to live a high quality
life?
Well,
we kind of know that already.
I mean,
it's kind of obvious.
No need friends,
need intimate relationships,
lead meaningful work,
you know,
how are you more money than we'll pay
your pills,
doesn't seem to help that much,
etc. Etc.
So it's likE,
you know,
it's like intelligent moderation and
disciplines.
Very boring.
It'S exactly what you'd expect.
if you were pessimistic about
excitement,
performance prediction,
we're going to look very carefully at
the nature of the traits that make
people successful in life.
And you know,
you might say,
well,
what do you mean by successful?
You know,
one of the things I mean is not in too
much pain and anxiety is that turns out
to actually be more important to people
than being happy.
You know,
if you say to people,
what do you want?
They say I want to be happy,
but if you analyze what they mean by
happy,
they mostly need not suffering and not
terrified.
You get those two things under control.
Like the worst that can happen to you is
that you'll be bored.
And then we'll wrap it up at the end.
Okay.
so that's the course.
So I'm,
I'm glad to be teaching it.
It's good to see all of you here.
It looks like you're trying to have a
comfortable classroom,
so that's kind of nice.
Decide if you decide if you want to take
the course because I don't want you to
be disappointed that.
So I'm really,
really telling you seriously to like
ideas.
If you like this lecture to like the
course and you got to do the reading and
there's a fair bit of free.
So
we'll see if there's.